c
bonjour bonjour
oui
comment sans frontières à l'est en temps
histoire
monsieur un petit test d'effort cruz
monsieur restée sans effet
oui bonjour bonjour j'ai rendez vous
avec madame philibert des ressources
humaines très bien allô allô bien le
téléphone fonctionne bien
vous êtes monsieur alors j'ai trois noms
parmi jelly sissoko lanthier dentier
voilà ce mot fonctionne à l'eau oui
madame philibert g monsieur lanthier à
l'accueil entrent et sortent et rentrent
et sortent et rentrent et sortent et
rentrent et sortent est entré très bien
cette part tombe bien c'est vous
je vais vous c'est vous voulez vous
asseyez vous cette chaise fonctionne ce
que vous avez important c'est vrai
monsieur lanthier alors monsieur
lanthier si vous êtes ici c'est vous
n'êtes pas ailleurs et si notre base et
hier c'est que vous êtes
c'est que vous êtes ici très bien donc
vos réponses fonctionne parler d'un
petit peu de vos principales qualités
pour ce poste
je fonce a pas besoin de tester dix fois
quelque chose avant de me lancer
quitte à prendre un risque j'adore ça
les risques c'est ce qui me maintient en
vivre je vois très bien monsieur gentil
je me suis désolé mais vous n'avez pas
le poste merci monsieur lancé vous
n'avez pas le poste pour les raisons que
vous savez vous convenez oui oui j'ai
bien compris
alors monsieur lanthier break je ne peux
pas vous donner travail parce que ici
cette entreprise si vous voulez c'est
comme une sorte de une tarte voilà c'est
une tarte aux quetsches et vous vous
êtes une fraise
vous êtes une phrase qui arrivent et qui
plonge dans cet univers donc c'est notre
refus fonctionne merci
la drh fonctionne
nadera jonction le dictaphone aussi
je te vois si la table des traitements
fonctionnent c'est ça que tu me prends
ce n'était pas un test je te laisse
travail
premier sketch youtube en tant qu'auteur
c'est un sketch et anticipation puisque
société